foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing Wizarding economics
specifically why and how a magical world
would still have impoverished people but
the Advent of magical capabilities how
can there possibly be witches and
wizards living derelict Lifestyles at
the very least shouldn't Every Witch
Wizard be able to Source some clean
clothes in Harry Potter there are many
passages alluding to the lack of
economic stability in certain Wizarding
families with a particular focus on
Weasleys from their house to their
hand-me-down robes it's certainly no
secret that the Weasleys were
financially stretched Draco Malfoy even
makes a comment towards Ron where He
suggests that the Weasley family name is
synonymous with this sort of thing I
think my name's funny do you well no
need to ask yours red hair and a
hand-me-down robe you must be a Weasley
and when Harry first Witnesses the
Weasley family vault is at a loss for
words Harry enjoyed the Breakneck
Journey Down to the Weasley's vaults but
felt Dreadful far worse than he had in
nocturnality when it was opened there
was a very small pile of silver sickles
inside and just one gold Galleon Mrs
Weasley felt right into the corners
before sweeping the whole lot into her
bag but the Weasleys weren't the only
characters in the Harry Potter story
that were lacking in funds in fact in my
opinion one of the most extreme examples
of poverty in Harry Potter is Remus
Lupine it's reinforced over and over and
over that his clothes are Tatty and that
he looked sickly the first time that
were introduced to lupine's character
he's described as follows the stranger
was wearing an extremely shabby set of
wizards robes that had been darned in
several places he looked ill and
exhausted though quite young his light
brown hair was flacked with gray it's on
his case she replied
the luggage rack over the man's head
where there was a small battered case
held together with a large quantity of
neatly knotted string the name Professor
RJ Lupine was stamped across one corner
in peeling letters then again the
Sorting ceremony Professor Lupine looked
particularly shabby next to all the
other teachers in their best robes when
Harry encounters Lupine for the second
time after their arrival at Hogwarts the
passage even suggests that Lupine had
eaten properly for the first time in a
while Lupine smiled vaguely and placed
his tassial briefcase on the teacher's
desk he was as shabby as ever but looked
healthier than he had on the train as
though he had had a few Square meals was
Lupine so poor that he couldn't afford
food how can this be a reality in
Wizarding Society first of all I'd like
to state that I appreciate that each of
these examples can be somewhat explained
via their unique circumstances in the
Weasley family there were a lot of
mounts to feed and one primary stream of
income as for Lupine well he was a
werewolf and that meant that getting
work was exceedingly difficult JK
Rowling expanded on this in an interview
Remus lived a hand-to-mouth existence
taking jobs that were far below his
level of ability always knowing that he
would have to leave them before his
pattern of growing sick once a month at
the full moon was noticed by his
workmates but bearing all of this in
mind I still can't help but Wonder with
the Advent of magic how is it possible
that poverty can exist on this level as
an outsider looking in it seems like
magic would be more than enough of an
advantage to make sure there's at least
food on the table at the very least I
think that even the lowest standards of
living were still significantly elevated
than what we might witness in the Muggle
world but here's the thing The Wizarding
World is an economy just like our own
with mediums of exchange and a system of
Finance they even have their own
Wizarding money coming in many different
forms including galleons sickles and
Canucks yes that's right it's pronounced
canutz galleons are the largest form of
currency equivalent to about 17 sickles
or 493 canads and just because it's a
magical world it doesn't suddenly mean
that things are going to be free
services and goods require payments
bearing this in mind I want to pose the
question is it an advantage to be
magical or is the Wizarding population
just as reliant on a functioning economy
as the rest of us God witches and
wizards simply create food money
clothing or shelter using magic what are
the limitations here what we first need
to remember is that magikar's law is
just like everything else magic can be
pretty remarkable but it still has its
limits one of the main things that comes
to mind in this context is gamp's law
against law of Elemental Transfiguration
is a fundamental property of magic and
magical law which identifies what can
and cannot be conjured conjuration is a
form of transfiguration in effect the
law articulates that one cannot create
something out of nothing while some have
mistaken Camp's law for a piece of
Wizarding legislation in reality the law
is simply a scientific Axiom a law of
magic itself there are five principal
exceptions to Camp's law with only one
being focused on in Canon which pertain
to food this is referenced in the books
your mother can't produce food out of
thin air no one can vood is the first of
the five principal exceptions to gamp's
law of Elemental Transfiguration it's
impossible to make good food out of
nothing you can summon it if you know
where it is you can transform it you can
increase the quantity if you've already
got some and when food seemingly came
out of nowhere in the books there was
always an explanation when McGonagall
produced a never-ending platter of
sandwiches it was food summoned from the
Hogwarts kitchens the same can be said
for the vast stretches of food presented
in the Hogwarts Banquet Hall during
student feasts but provided that this is
the only magical law pertaining to food
and that food can be multiplied I don't
really know what remus's excuse is for
being hungry he wasn't completely broke
he still had money here and there so why
didn't he just buy a small amount of
food and multiply it if this was an
option in the Muggle world I'm sure that
everyone would capitalize on it in my
opinion this is a bit of a plot hole
gap's law prohibited him from creating
food out of nothing but it didn't stop
him from multiplying or enlarging food
in his possession I don't think there's
really any proper explanation for him
being as hungry as he was portrayed to
be when Harry first meets him but moving
on I wonder what the exceptions are to
this magical law given that gamp's law
seems to be centered around conjuration
I think it's reasonable able to infer
that the other four exceptions were
simply other categories of substances
which could also not be created from
nothing if you guys want a video on all
of them then leave a comment down below
but for now I'm going to just focus on
one more based on what I know about
Wizarding Society I suspect that one of
the other main exceptions is somehow
related to money or gold this would
explain why some witches and wizards
don't have a lot of it and would also
explain how Wizarding poverty could
exist at all it's also likely that the
exceptions with gold were deeper rooted
than food as if gold could be multiplied
as food could be then it still wouldn't
really be any kind of an issue being too
lazy to multiply on your own gold is not
exactly an excuse for being poor so I
imagine it's just not a possibility
furthermore if it was possible to
transfigure things into gold then the
Quest for the fabled Philosopher's Stone
which does just that would not have been
going on for centuries in conclusion The
Wizarding economy which so closely
resembles our own absolutely leaves the
door open for poverty at least on some
level the only difference between those
without wealth and the Muggle world and
magical world is that witches and
wizards were able to multiply their food
sources this is a massive Advantage but
besides that magic doesn't necessarily
appear to be of much help and that's it
for this video If you enjoyed it please
like the video and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember it is
the quality of one's convictions that
determine success not the number of
followers
[Music]